قد تبدو فكره امتلاك البشر لاجنحه او
مخالب او ذراع اضافيه امرا خياليا الى حد
ما لكن هذه السيناريوهات يمكن ان تصبح
حقيقه في العقود القليله المقبله وذلك
بفضل الاطراف البشريه فقد نجح الباحثون
بالفعل في اضافه ابهام ثالث ليد بشريه يتم
التحكم بها باستخدام مستشعرات الضغط
المتصله باقدامهم ونقلا عن خبراء تحدثوا
لصحيفه ديلي ميل البريطانيه فان اضافه
الابهام هي مجرد خطوه اولى نحو اضافات
اكبر واكثر لجسم الانسان
وتجربه اضافه ابهام سادس اذا فتحت نافذه
امام امكانيه اضافه اطراف اخرى بهذا
الخصوص قالت تمارمكين وهي استاذه علم
الاعصاب الادراكي في جامعه كامبريدج ان
قدره الدماغ على التكيف مع طرف اضافي كانت
غير عاديه وعندما سئلت عما اذا كان من
الممكن تصميمه اجنحه او حتى مخالب للانسان
والاستخدام البشري قالت البروفيسور ماكين
ان الامر ممكن من منظور تقني فتقنيات
موجوده وهناك حاجه فقط الى توسيع نطاقها